that guy is the [ __ ] sleeper of the
185-pound division the fact that he went
over to Bellator very [ __ ]
fascinating to me he just wrecked Rory
MacDonald completely wrecked them right
to watch boys should not be fighting at
185 pounds especially against the guy
who's fought at 205 he's held titles at
205 I agree especially a guy in Gegard
Mousasi who's just as talented just a
skill so and then maybe go better might
be better than some other assets then
when you go skill for skill then size
comes into play and you saw how that
pans out or crushing system sauce
there's a giant dick how would he know
he was in a sauna next to him oh that
makes sense though you know why is it
John sauce he has that big dick energy
like he just carries himself like a
straight badass dummy like nothing
really gets him going you know why
because a giant dead giant dick you know
what birds birds probably right on this
thing sense
goddess makes a brilliant bright sure I
mean it's not even like you figured it
out I mean he's got like eyewitness
don't you think that there is in the
room nothing's ever made more sense than
that hot cedar box with a big old sweaty
dick dude that gay guard amped and
everyone's like how come he doesn't get
more emotional because he's the fattest
dick in the world he swore it was bigger
than his [ __ ] water bottle I go he
goes dude I'm telling you it was giant
Wow all right that makes sense man
it does make a lot of sense yeah but
Gegard Mousasi not now belt or is an
interesting kind of predicament because
they have that welterweight tournament
going on now you have your champ who was
gonna enter the tournament as the title
holder and the first round supposed to
fight John Fitch who isn't an easy fight
but he just coming off a loss and got
destroyed and also it looks like you had
some nose damage which was his issue
before
yeah his nose had been [ __ ] up for a
long time and you know he decided to
take a whole year off just to try to fix
his nose
just try to let it heal that's serious
yeah whole year off I mean think about
that was like part of the delay in his
initial fight in Bellator was that he
left the UFC you know he his nose got
smashed in the robbie lawler fight I
mean that was hard to watch
everyone who's in agony on the ground
because his nose just shattered they
said every time we get hit it just go
white like sparks he couldn't see any oh
it was a bad injury I think so he said
there is one of the best fights of all
time by the grace one of the greatest
fight or he earned that [ __ ] but now
with Rory you know what's sad too and
it's happened to me it's happened to
some other fighters I'm sure Rory goes I
just think it I just didn't feel like
fighting I did I was in and wasn't in
the zone just didn't feel like fighting
gig over me so see that night who it's a
gay garden you know saw see who he
doesn't get enough recognition how good
that he is absolute monster you got to
think about all the guys that he's
beaten he's on like a six or seven fight
win streak which includes Chris Weidman
Vitor Belfort a latest who's the guy in
Bellator the former champion Sheila
menko yeah I was getting I was coming I
went come Shevchenko that's [ __ ] up
this girl they were slumming go man yeah
he's an absolute night monster there's a
monster I'm surprised UFC let him go now
when I say let him go just didn't
matches his contract you know cuz belt
or probably offered more and they're
like I'll work good yes he could use
them right now yeah well I mean it's
like they had Yoel Romero
they've got Robert Whittaker was a champ
they've got so much going on at 185 but
gay guard might be the best I mean he's
certainly in the running if you looked
at it objectively it's entirely possible
if he's not number one he's he's number
two top three he's number three
yeah but Austin you look at his fight
with if him and Robert Whittaker were to
fight that's not an easy pick I'm fine
you would have to you like damn that's
the [ __ ] fight you might favor K
guard you don't know how big and long a
nice grab I personally listen Robert
Whittaker is a monster he's phenomenal
at least for now
but so Mousasi so was Mousasi and
Mousasi has a full game man his ground
game is phenomenal and the biggest dick
in the division giant dick that has
really taking the consideration at all
this might be no yo Elza bet it's bigger
no way
it's no bro he doesn't care that Energon
it's too aggressive why it's yeah when
you're that aggressive you don't have
that fat oh there's no way he looks like
that and doesn't have a big dick